patrick besson tu va inaugurer une
nouvelle forme d'interviews et je vais
te balancer un certain nombre de noms
propres et à chaque fois tu vas me
donner ta réaction je commence avec
pouchkine par hasard
[Musique]
un adolescent au teint mat marchand
triste que l'anglais temps et nous
obsède depuis ce temps le bruit si les
jets ne sais pas c'est le héros de temps
dernier roman qui s'appelle la statue de
la description par anna akhmatova
d'alexandre s'est aggravée du push qui
n'ont peu héros de mon roman
nathalie pouchkine à sa famille quelques
conseils naissent de la fressange oui
oui elle ressemble beaucoup à l'aise
c'était une grande fille brune très
belle comme ça très bien fait très
amusant eugène onéguine ce vieil aux
gènes et ben c'est le titre du roman en
vers de pouchkine
pouchkine à 25 26 ans annonce sa mort en
duel cirque la mort du poète lenski en
duel contre jeune jean c'est la mort de
pouchkine contre georges danthez le
supposé amant de sa femme mais je refuse
cette version et tout ça dans thales n'a
jamais couché avec la télé bougez
floride où la nappe un opéra rock
roland leroy roland l'herron attends tu
bosses gratos pour lui enfin pour lui et
pour tout les polices de l'humanité non
qu'il est joli ballet jazz et j'espère
moi j'avais jamais lu tes papiers dans
l'humanité mais j'avoue qu'ils sont très
drôles
bah oui monsieur encourage vivement les
téléspectateurs allaient mais s'ils
veulent pas acheter l'humanité ils sont
édités chez messidor de temps en temps
en temps on en a fait un il ya un an qui
s'appelait amicalement rouge et laon
fonds d'emprunt bientôt qui s'appellera
intifada
gorbatchev un bon russe 5 rbds parce que
tu t'étonnes comprennent toujours des
nouvelles de la santé de sakharov et
puis pas des epa les ouvriers français
prestement à la santé de sakhir elle va
mieux se félicite pour lui pour la femme
et pour tout virus parce que c'est un
homme intéressant ce problème évidemment
c'est un type qui a inventé la bombe
atomique russe a travaillé dessus ça
m'amuse à l'époque les gens réclament la
libération d'un type dont il craignait
qu'on leur envoie la bombe
la chance m'a dit je suis ravi qu'il
soit libre
john lipsky quand il prononcera ben
jarry lipsky comme avant sinon ouais si
tu veux t'en c'est un type avec des
lunettes noires
jean marie rouart le roi des animaux
ouais puis tu ne fais pas vue et l'ouïe
pascontent figaro un peu peu c'est vrai
que tu as déjà deux appartements
ouais comment tu as fait pour qu'il y
ait deux à part ça tant mieux dit non tu
me wrong poing sur la gueule
seulement moi et la transparence sont
chers amis quelle transparence et reste
au lit car les appartements absolument
rien on fait donc ils devraient relire
le livre de gorbatchev
il n'y a pas un mot sur les appartements
avant ils disent pas comment il
s'appelle à la natural c'est la triste
saison de la télé qu'il lui faudrait y
habiter là-bas nimier mais on m'a
toujours plu pour 1 us à moi ils sont
plutôt ce pays annonce du coup scuderia
cause du charbon et a fait la guerre
dans ce pays
moi j'étais en allemagne en espagne à
l'époque où il faisait la guerre c'est à
dire en allemagne parce que j'ai occupés
ben c'est drôle parce que je rachète
tous ses vivres en ce moment
je les fais relier mais je les relis
plus et rythme mon mur qu'isabelle
adjani tout feu tout flamme
sa femme sa madone ta mère un buzz
soleil michael jackson chirurgie
esthétique à vue de nez prince ben un
copain et huawei des pda
ah oui alors c'est le type de la
banlieue de londres qui a réussi là
aiment beaucoup ce qui fait un bond ppda
alors oui c'est un type de la banlieue
ouest
thierry ardisson alors là je peux te
dire vraiment c'est bien si la
nouvelle-zélande pays mais quand même
c'est bon écrivain malgré tout malgré
tous ses défauts mais c'est aussi le
sens de mon lit parce que le sens de mon
livre c'est qu'un écrivain il faut être
tout ce qu'il veut
si c'est un bon écrivain moi je suis
partant aujourd'hui et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu